if I could live on the moon I would
rather stay in Tennessee Sarah Hyland
and Wells Adams are engaged pipe dream
not anymore
the 35 year old bachelor nation star got
down on bended knee while on a tropical
vacation after nearly two years of
dating the 28 year old Modern Family
star Wells shared the suite proposal
video to Instagram captioning it in part
I'll be Johnny you be June but forever
[Music]
Sarah also shared a set of photos to her
account showing off what we all want to
see that massive diamond ring what are
you looking for he knows what it is so
it's fine
apparently so the oval diamond appears
to be by Lorraine Schwartz Sarah tagged
the jeweler in the pics and gushed in
the caption that can't eat can't sleep
reach for the stars over the fence world
series kind of stuff which is a
reference to the Olsen twins classic it
takes two I know we both needed a win
and we got one I don't think we do
anything different I don't think we're
just like any normal relationship
congratulations to the happy couple
[Music]